[Música]
então a gente discuta o nervosismo
sei lá os dirigentes gostam muito de
falar dele então você é uma ilha como eu
falo com meus amigos sempre então o
pequeno coletivo ele começou com uma
idéia muito simples eu ia pra sempre
fazer um piquenique e um momento com
meus amigos eu comentei com o pessoal
que eu vou fazer um piquenique coletivo
foi lá que em um evento no facebook só
que eu não imaginava a proporção do do
evento que eu esperava tipo ao meu amigo
30 pessoas
no primeiro pique nique jádel tipo as
300 pessoas
aí eu comecei a pensar nossa eu acho que
ele é um grande projeto na nossa cidade
então daí tipo depois foi acontecendo de
mais edições aí eu trouxe umas falas do
pessoal que que vai no piquenique que já
foi todas as edições da canoa litoral
sul de florianópolis
o pequeno que aquele evento que um mês
atrás felicidade é saber que sábado
sempre vai ficar mais bonito mais alegre
mais aconchegante porque se não existe
mas é melhor que está rodeado de amigos
em um espaço público da cidade é repleto
de coisas boas
se não jogar conversa fora rever os
antigos colegas na região prestigiar a
cultura municipal e apreciar uma boa
música e 6 natureza é o amor coletivo e
forma de piquenique tossia um piquenique
ele não tem ligação nenhuma com a
prefeitura ele é todo de tv the
independent é eu tenho o apoio dos
amigos
um amigo me dá um banheiro químico outro
nome presta tendo outra empresa que
presta o som é então assim ele é todo
independente eu acho que é por isso que
se tem esse sentimento muito forte que é
é uma batalha todo mês agora a cada dois
meses está acontecendo pra acontecer
isso na nossa cidade e eu trago tipo eu
tenho e organiza exposições assim a se
preocupar com bastante artista
independente a gente vai lá passar a
tarde a gente pinta é ele expõe os
trabalhos pelo as pessoas com
é seu pessoal os artistas né e tem os
direitos que vão discotecar já teve
banda aqui foi uma primeira edição né do
piquenique
só assim a gente é na primeira edição
assim tipo como eu não esperava já já no
1º em são paulo 300 mais umas 300
pessoas
então se a gente não estiver não tinham
como conseguir banheiro químico e foi
uma coisa bem simples assim de pva caixa
de som daí começou a pessoa começou a
parecer começou a levar comida e aquilo
ali já já eu comecei a imaginar que
aquilo virado um grande projeto
ainda na nas próximas edições e já cria
página
hoje ele já tá né já está todo formal e
o piquenique ele teve uma proporção tão
grande que vem gente de muito lugar vem
gente de porto alegre torres é da região
aqui tipo do barão floripa
eu já vi gente de são paulo gente que
foi uma coisa muito impressionante é um
é uma parte é uma parte que as pessoas
vão para poder se divertir trocar uma
idéia eu já soube de várias histórias do
piquenique gente começou a namorar gente
que revê um amigo de dez anos atrás
aí tem um pessoal que ele que leva as
suas artes pessoal que passa a tarde
toda com as idéias aqui já é na segunda
edição e flash lite é muito muito
importante diploma vai ser muito boa no
começo achei que poderia ter selecção
que tenho muita gente também tive
problemas com o lixo aí no próximo já
teve o pessoal que ajudou hoje tipo leva
muitos sacos de lixo da edição eu vou eu
vou falando com o pessoal a respeito do
lixo pessoal já está mais 58 s jamais
também dedicado no final de cada edição
o pessoal me ajuda
o lixo está muito está muito bonita seu
tipo
ali a ideia do piquenique é essa é um
coletivo todo mundo se junta todos
ajudando fica é um das últimas edições
que tipo socorro à praça né então assim
a é como eu falei é independente e
democrático
então sempre todo o mês lutando para
conseguir banheiro químico conseguir
trazer esposito expositor ontem muito
pessoal do de movimentos na da cidade
lgbt é do coletivo feminista que eles
vão lá ele expõe trabalhos esse protesto
eles foram 2 mil coisas do biquíni que é
bem interessante reunião se projeto ele
como falei e já faz parte da minha vida
meu organismo
eu morro e vi todo na quem posta no quem
faz o evento que o evento e eu quem
possa que faz toda a tensão sou eu quem
vai de manhã e monta a tenda o pessoal
sou eu quem fotografa e quibe sou eu
quem pouca do piquenique sou eu quem
manda sou eu e quem junto isso sou eu e
theo tipo eu estou inteiramente no
projeto
então se é difícil eu participar da seu
queria muito sentar lá e e passar a
tarde o pessoal só que eu não consigo
então eu também sei falar merda que
estão sempre na correria mas é porque
tem eu acho que tem que ter que eu tenho
que está ali é como eu falo com meus
amigos para todos os meus filhos e vou
cuidar deles todos ali e o piquenique
que eu falei ele já faz parte da minha
vida e eu acho que é muito importante
ter um projeto dessa nossa cidade de
rede bastante pessoas e o pessoal se
sente tão bem
gente é uma coisa tão simples pessoal na
praça leva comida eles interagem eles
fazem novas amizades e eu acho que isso
aí paro pra gente hoje nem culturalmente
é essencial assim ó 800 hálito conhecer
pessoas novas que passar uma tarde a
conhecer artistas tu todo independente
que talvez não conhece eu tenho um
artista na cidade eu não conheço o nosso
filho piquenique conhecer aquele menino
ou se interessante
quero quero conhecer mais o trabalho
dele e eu acho que o piquenique e
aprendi bastante nessa parte do tanto da
arte da da interação eu termino com a
mesma pergunta né
o que é o pequeno coletivo e pra quem
não conhece o piquenique
eu convido para sentir
pensei se junto de todo o pessoal que
vão lá na praça do congresso saia
obrigada
[Aplausos]